Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Final Nights 3.
*Beep*
Hey! Hi! What do I do? I don't know what to do... Oh god...
What are you doing outside my window?
*ominous noise*
Hi...!
How's it going?
I'm just gonna stare death in the face 'cause I got no other alternative!!
Boy, you got a lovely smile!
*ominous laughter*
Eugh, that ain't good.
*Shrieks in panic* Fuck off!
I'm dead. I don't know how to play! *laughs*
*Beep*
Oh, what??
What am I doing? What am I doing?!
I don't know what's happening..
That's one intimidating c*l*ock right there...
A great big c*l*ock!
Come in a- *moaning noise from monster*
That ain't a good sound. I can't do anything!
*Keyboard clicks* I'm pressing buttons!
AHHH! I got my defenses at maximum!
*Smack*
Maximum efficiency!
*Clock chimes*
Wooo!!!
I did something!
*sobbing* I don't know what I did!
*Beep*
*Rumble of thunder*
Ehhh...
Hello. BOO!
*Thunderclap*
Ahh! Fuck you! *laughs* What the fuck?
Why did I go confront him?!
*Beep*
Floof the hair! FOR POWER! *explosion*
I really am expecting something to pop out, but apparently nothing wants to say hi to me.
I must be so adorable when I sleep.
*Grandfather clock chiming*
I win! Again.
Whaa-a-at?
AHHH!
Okay, alright, I guess I'm dead.
*Beep*
[First video]
Hi! What are you doing outside my window?
Are you cleep-clreepy-cllll-creep-creepering in?
[Second video]
We were just having a bromance and you-
You made it all weird, CHAD!
[Third video]
Certainly not gonna shove this fork into this power plug. *giggles*
Here baby, baby, baby.
That's one intimating clock right there..
A great big
c[CENSORED]